One problem with pinhole cameras, is that
the images that they create are very, very
dim and that's one of the reasons that they
are so hard to capture and the reason that
the images are dim, is if we look at all the
light rays that emerge from a particular point,
in this example, only one of those light rays
goes through and forms the image, the rest
of the light rays hit the opaque plane and
are absorbed or reflected off to somewhere else.
So if we want to make our image brighter we
need to be able to utilize more of the light
rays that are leaving the object and the way
we do that, is to use a lens.
A lens is a very simple technique for gathering
more of the light rays that leave a particular
point in the world. Again we have our graphical
example and we can see the light rays leaving
one particular point, they've all passed through
the lens and strike the image plane. So here
we've captured many, many more light rays,
so the image that we form will be brighter.
We can describe this a bit more formally.
We consider the distance away from the lens
plane which we will call the distance F and
the diameter of the lens which is the distance
Phi and we can create a number, which is generally
referred to as the F number of the lens, which
is the ratio of F to Phi. The F number of
the lens is typically inscribed on the front
of the lens; in this case it's a F1.4 lens
so that means capital F equals 1.4. The smaller
the F number the greater is the light gathering
power of the lens, the brighter image that
it will create. Let's simplify things and
see how lenses work.
We have a simple object in the world and we
have a lens. And a lens is described by a
focal length and in this case we have what
we call a thin lens model. This is probably
familiar to you from high school physics.
The real lenses that you have in your camera
are not simple lenses like this, but they
can be approximated by a single lens.
The lens is described by two focal points,
each a distance F away from the centre plane
of the lens. To see where the image of the
object falls, we perform this very simple
geometry and the small arrow shows where the
image will be formed. It's the intersection
of the two yellow lines. This image formation
process is described quite simply mathematically,
the distance of the object which we call "Zo"
the distance at which the image is formed
"Zi" is related by this equation here, so
Zi is the distance away from the centre of
the lens, where a sharp image will be formed
and that's what we call the "Image Plane."
That's where the image is formed and that's
where we put the sensor. Now the sensor might
have been a piece of film in the old days,
today it's much more likely that we place
a semiconductor imaging chip; a large array
of light sensitive elements and the output
of this array is recorded digitally and placed
into the flash memory in the phone or the
camera.
Now let's look at what happens if I move the
object a little bit closer to the lens. The
value of Zo has been reduced and we do the
geometric construction, we see now that the
image is formed in a different place; Zi has
got a different value, as given by the equation
down the bottom. What this means is that if
I had the image plane in the original location,
I would have a fuzzy image there; that image
would be out of focus.
In order to create a focussed image, I need
to move the image plane over to here and if
I place the image plane there, then I will
have a sharp image of my object. And so this
is what happens when I adjust the focus of
an old fashioned type camera. As I rotate
the lens in order to focus it, there's a screw
thread there which is actually moving the
lens away from the plane of the sensor or
the film. So in order to focus a camera, what
I need to do is to change the distance between
the lens and the plane where the image is
formed and captured.
Here's an animation that shows this. As the
object moves towards the lens, we can see,
just using the simple geometric construction,
that the location of the image is moving further
and further away from the lens, so in order
to bring it into focus, I need to move the
image plane away from the lens.
Interestingly a pinhole camera does not require
focussing. Irrespective of the distance of
the object, the image that it forms is always
sharp, but the disadvantage of the pinhole
lens as I mentioned earlier, is that the images
are very, very faint. So it doesn't need focussing
but it doesn't produce bright images.